students walk out of their schools for
gun control to the delight of the media
stormy Daniels gets the red-carpet
treatment and President Trump talks
trade in the weirdest possible way I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
so we have a lot to get to today as I
predicted yesterday all of the walkouts
turned out to be just a media propaganda
campaign on behalf of gun control it was
not about solidarity with the slain
students it was not really about
mourning over the slain students it was
not about America coming together around
the cause of stopping violence in
schools it was a gun control program
that's all that was happening yesterday
all across the country it was not a
unifying moment it was a divisive one it
needn't have been we'll get to all of
that in just a second first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
wink so I know that you spent a little
bit of time at the beginning of the year
trying to wean yourself off the alcohol
because you thought it was gonna make
your life happier well it didn't it
turns out it's time for you to relax a
little bit not only that it's time for
you to make sure that when you go over
to your friend's house and you need to
bring a bottle of wine you don't look
like a schmuck for bringing the worst
kind of wine this is what wink is for so
wink come winc it's a great resource and
it makes enjoying downtime that much
easier and it ensures that you don't
look like an ignoramus when you bring a
bottle of wine to your friend's house
here's how it works
you go over to try wink calm slash bend
it's t ry winc comm slash bend and then
you have a profile palate profile quiz
it asks you questions about what sort of
foods you like what sort of foods you
like to eat together and then they
translate that into a recommendation so
I'll ask how do you take your coffee or
how do you feel about blueberries and
then they give you a wine recommendation
and they send you wines curated to your
taste so the more wines you rate the
more personalized your monthly
selections that become and each month
there are delicious new wines like the
insanely popular summer water rose a
folks around the office have tried these
wines they say they are top-notch no
membership fees you can skip any month
you can cancel anytime and shipping is
covered so if you don't like a bottle
they send you they will replace it with
a bottle that you will love
no questions asked try it today go to
try wink comm slash been try wink comm
slash been you get 20 bucks off your
first shipment that's t ry winc comm
slash man again $20 off your first
shipment pretty spectacular deal try
blink comm / Ben and again they'll help
you pick the best pile of wine and then
will ensure that you enjoy your evening
t ry winc comm / Ben you get $20 off and
it lets them know that we sent you as
well okay so yesterday wall-to-wall
coverage of all of the students walking
out of their school so first we need to
ask how does such a thing get planned is
such a thing spontaneous do you have a
situation here where thousands hundreds
of thousands of student
I was just getting up and walking out of
school at the same time because they
heard online they were supposed to do so
or are they being told by their teachers
and the teachers unions and all the
leftist administrators at school that
it's a good thing for them to get up and
leave class because I guarantee you that
if I had gotten up in ditched class in
high school there would have been some
sort of some sort of excuse note needed
right you don't just get to leave class
in the middle of class when you're in
junior high or high school you actually
have to have an excuse for doing so
otherwise you are a truant right
so here the schools themselves are
writing the excuse notes now let me just
ask a question that's been asked by a
lot of folks on the right let's say
there were a pro-life walkout tomorrow
how many of these teachers do you think
would be okay with the students leaving
if all the students just got up and
walked outside to protest for 10 minutes
the 1 million abortions plus in the
United States per year if every student
in America did that how many of those
teachers do you think would excuse the
students and how many of them do you
think would actually punish the students
how many do you think would dock the
students in some way in other words one
of the problems here is that you have
these leftist propaganda centers called
our public schools that are taught by
teachers who are members of teachers
unions who are Democratic Party cronies
and then they use that position in order
to promulgate a certain agenda so all
these students get up and they walk out
of course this thing really was
organized in astroturf by the women's
March and they use the same
organizational structures in order to
push it and the women's March of course
run by some of the worst people on
planet Earth
members of the louis farrakhan
contingent and so they organized this
whole thing as a gun-control push now
what was so annoying about this and I
discussed it yesterday I've read a bunch
of letters from students and I have a
thousand more today I mean I really I
must have received at least 250 emails
yesterday from students around the
country who are upset about how they
were treated yesterday during these walk
outs yet I was hearing from tons of
people yesterday this was going to
happen than it did that this turned into
a propaganda effort that this was never
about solidarity with the students that
if you said listen I am in favor of gun
rights and I also feel terrible for what
happened for the students that you were
treated like garbage the most obvious
example of this is clip 13 so yesterday
there was a clip that was going around
the internet pretty amazing one of the
students walked out of class and did
what I suggested right brought a sign
that was a pro Second Amendment sign
that also expressed sympathy for the
children who are killed and he was
escorted from the protest right he was
told he couldn't
the protests and they actually try to
push him into a police car here sort of
look like yesterday so he was told to
leave you as told he couldn't stand with
all of the students because for some
reason or other that was just
unacceptable now if you've been holding
a sign that said stop guns now do you
think that would have happened to him
the answer of course is no the video is
posted to Facebook by Kenny McDonald's
is a student at New Prague High School
in New Prague Minnesota the short video
does not show what took place before
after the principal singled out the
student here's what McDonald's said he
says kids at our school today walked out
in honor of the 17 students killed in
Florida students held signs that said
arm our teachers they had two signs a
student walked out without saying a word
peacefully put up a sign which said guns
don't kill people people kill people and
he was escorted off the property by our
principal and threatened to be put in a
police car this violates the First
Amendment it makes me sick that they can
do whatever they want please make this
go viral so it's not been verified that
the student story is the entire truth
left to hear from the school exactly
what happened but is there a question
that if the student had been holding a
sign that said gun control now that
everything would have been fine for him
I have very little doubt that's the case
it was obvious what the network's we're
trying to do here it's obvious what the
media we're trying to do here again
these are the same media whoever you're
ignore the March for Life which draws
hundreds of thousands of people to
Washington DC and the coverage is always
scant and minimal even though it's a
huge number of young people who are
going to that particular March I mean
this big school walkout that is
sponsored by the left yesterday and it's
widely covered by the media and of
course they're always you know I don't
want to slander all the students who
walked out as people who are just taking
advantage although I will say that you
know if I were a student in high school
and I had the choice between sitting in
class and walking out and ditching I
would ditch right there that's true for
the vast majority of students so playing
it as though all of these students are
pro-gun control I think is silly
most students just go along to get along
just like most people go along to get
along particularly when they are told
that it makes them morally superior to
walk out of class for some sort of
clause or another but there there were
some students who decided to go wild in
Tennessee there were some students who
tore down an American flag and jumped on
a cop car during the walkout which is
just delightful so you can see them I
hear they're there walking around they
go over to the flagpole and they're
taking down the American flag I'm
turning the walkout which is just which
is glorious and here they are rush
a cop car so does it Antioch high school
I guess in Tennessee and making sure the
kids making trouble not not a grave
shock there you know we saw this before
I mean last week there was a walkout as
well and it was in California there a
bunch of students who essentially went
wild now that was not representative of
these rallies the only reason that I'm
pointing this out is to point out that
young people are supposed to be our
leaders sometimes are very stupid okay
just like old people are sometimes very
stupid and so granting them conferring
upon them some sort of grand in
intellectual legitimacy because they're
young seems to me really really foolish
this was in fact as I say a left
propaganda effort if you don't believe
me here's what it looked like when
Bernie Sanders showed up at the walkout
rights and no Republicans were invited
to the walkout no Republicans were
invited to speak at the walkout none of
them were invited to the steps of the
Capitol for the walkout but Bernie
Sanders walked out to join the students
in the gun protest and he was treated
like a hero this is a clip 15 actually
here's what it looked like when he was
walking through the crowd
[Applause]
right all the kids are going now oh my
god it's Bernie Sanders yeah but this
isn't a political rally right they're
all smiling and laughing and taking
pictures oh my god it's the old man the
old cuckoo let's put in what are we
gonna do but don't worry this had
nothing to politics folks this was
beyond politics this had nothing to do
with the political agenda this was just
about solidarity with the victims in
parkland it was not political in any way
this is the way the media were playing
it last night of course Bernie Sanders
speaking and shouting for gun control is
an amazing thing considering that Bernie
Sanders comes from Vermont to state with
very little gun control even though it
is very left state here's Bernie Sanders
speaking yesterday here crazy Oh bring
it you the young people of this country
are leading the nation please give me
money please for my next campaign the
time is now for me to pretend to be
relevant as though I had done anything
except run for president in my entire
career so Bernie Sanders stepping out
and of course you're not seeing any
actual discussion here now a guy who who
I've become friendly with Kyle cash of a
student over at Parkland at the Parkland
High School um he actually went around
on Capitol Hill didn't Bernie Sanders
Bernie Sanders has refused to meet with
him apparently they're a bunch of other
legislators legislators right and left
we have met with him and cash has done a
lot of the work that the the kids at the
other kids at his high school won't
where he's actually going around trying
to trying to speak with various members
and legislators spoke with Marco Rubio
and Bill Nelson he spoke with Chuck
Schumer and he spoke with and he spoke
with Paul Ryan
so he's met with a bunch of legislators
he met with President Trump the idea
here trying to come to some sort of
consensus about things that can be done
the kids at Marjory Stoneman high school
though they the ones who are being shown
on the media are not the ones who are
meeting with legislators on Capitol Hill
they are the ones instead of hearing on
Ellen and then shouting about how
America is a terrible horrible very bad
place where the old people suck right
they're the ones who go on Bill Maher
and say F my parents which is just a
great way of getting things done which
again shows this a lot about moral
posturing and not very much about
getting anything done you can see it the
media's bias here so Viacom networks
decided to go silent for 17 minutes in
order to this is Nickelodeon and
and I'll and MTV they went silent for 17
minutes in order to pay tribute to the
parkland students they would say oh this
isn't political at all except that I
don't remember them doing this after the
Boston Marathon bombing I don't remember
them doing this after the after of the
Orlando shooting I don't remember them
doing this after any terrorist act they
only do this after a particularly
that is driving a particular narrative
on a particular day at a particular time
when everyone else is walking out so
here's what it looked like on Viacom
networks last yesterday morning they
printed on their screen
Viacom stands with all students as they
participate in the National School
walkout against gun violence it's nuts
vh1 its TV Land it's its Paramount it's
Nick jr. and so if you're if you just
want to put your kid down for a second
heaven watching it's you know you
couldn't do that because Viacom was busy
protesting with all the kids listen
they're a corporation with this
corporate virtue signaling is really
amazing and it's obvious that all the
people in Hollywood who proclaim they
have no political agenda have a pretty
obvious political agenda they again they
would not do this if there were a school
walk out against the violence of the
murder of the unborn and there are many
many many more children who are killed
in the womb every year that are killed
in schools every year no question Viacom
does nothing it not only does nothing
probably put son Linda Ellerbee to talk
about why it is that abortion should be
legal and so there is a political agenda
on the part of the media and this is the
part that really is is galling it's the
part that kinda makes you sick to your
stomach a little bit is the lie that
this is a political I'm fine with you
politicking you own a politic go ahead
you and me pro-gun control fine with me
but don't pretend that it's news
coverage when CNN puts on a town hall
that is essentially a show trial on
behalf of gun control don't pretend that
that's neutral arbiter that that's you
being a neutral arbiter of the facts it
is not if you're the media and you
proclaim all you care about is ratings
on the one hand and and just pleasing
people on the other entertaining people
on the other then don't claim that this
is a political because this is not a
political it obviously is incredibly
political we're gonna get some of the
stuff that students had to say yesterday
again proving that 17 year old 17 year
olds don't know everything despite their
own maybe beliefs to the contrary well
we'll get to all of that in just second
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at texture so if you are
interested in making sure that the
information stream into your brain never
stops this is what the texture app is
for so I use it in my house to get all
of the leading titles like thyme the
Atlantic The New Yorker
Vanity Fair and wired right now you can
try texture for free the texture app
delivers unlimited access to over 200
premium magazines again it is it is just
fantastic so here's the way that it
works you go over to texture comm slash
Ben and you get a free trial that's just
for my listeners you get a free trial at
texture comm slash man if you choose to
continue then my listeners get a price
of $9.99 a month which is 30% off the
listed price over at textured comp so
you got your favorite magazines their
back issues anytime anywhere this means
you can browse the archives it means
that you'll never run out of reading
material suck at the airport it doesn't
matter you can still have stuff to read
you can still be getting informed
texture calm / meta and the list of
magazines is just it's a fantastic list
I mean it's everything from National
Geographic to Food Network Magazine to
Newsweek to Vanity Fair to Men's Fitness
& Entertainment Weekly I mean the
variety of magazines here is
extraordinarily high and magazine
journalism lately has been really good
like the Atlantic has done a lot of
really good long form journalism The New
Yorker of course broke the Weinsteins
story there's so much good journalism
happening in the magazine sphere but
you're not looking at it you're not
seeing it unless you go to texture so go
to texture comm /ban it could cost you
like $9.99 a month just to subscribe to
like two of these magazines at a time
make it 200 of them for the same price
texture comm / Ben get your free trial
today and if you choose to continue it's
just $9.99 a month after that so use
that slash pen so make sure you get the
special deal and let them know that we
sent you texture comm slash Ben okay so
here are some of the things that the
students had to say at this at this
rally again the rally was happening all
over the country so there was a set of
disparate rallies happening everywhere
here is a USA Today covering this as
though it is one of the great moments in
human history when in reality it's just
an astroturf
it's an astroturf leftist thing again
when teachers are telling students to
walk out this is teachers using students
to push their political agenda end of
story
there's not a bunch of students who are
voluntarily deciding that they want to
get together in a walkout it's not
grassroots this is being done from top
down when teachers tell students that
it's time to walk out when teachers
inform students it's time to walk out
and students walk out that's really on
the teachers not on the students I'm not
blaming the students but I'm also not
gonna pretend that this was led by
students it wasn't it was led by a bunch
of adults who decided they were going to
work with a couple of students and use
those students as a prop in order to
push a particular agenda again not
ripping on the students students can
have their own beliefs that's fine I
like the kids are politically active a
lot of people
was in my program are people who are
under the age of 18 that's wonderful be
politically active enjoy but we're going
to analyze your arguments with the same
seriousness we would analyze anyone
else's arguments and we also cannot
pretend that this entire thing was just
some spontaneous uprising of the people
and that everybody just decided all the
sudden that like they're trying to
portray this is like it's the Arab
Spring like it there's this horrible
superstructure run by the NRA and Dana
lash and now all those people have to be
brought well that's not what's happening
here
what's happening here is a bunch of
teachers union members are telling their
students we're all gonna walk out at a
particular time a bunch of principals
are green lighting it and then a bunch
of students are saying well what the
hell if everybody else is walking out I
may as well at least I don't look like a
jerk that way so here are some of the
students who are speaking at the
walkouts this is from USA Today every
day no we have been taught for
containment drills shut off the lights
lock the door go and the thought that's
not okay if every time someone dies for
a shooting we brush it off as oh it's
just another casualty that's not okay
pausing for one second okay first of all
like no one is brushing this stuff off
and number no one is brushing the stuff
off second this is not happening every
day clearly it's not happening every day
the number of school shootings in
America is on the decline
third would you not want to I mean we
teach kids stop drop and roll from the
time that they are 5 years old right we
teach them what's happening case of a
fire we teach them for four generations
in this country we taught people in case
of nuclear attack get under your desk
for all that help that would do you
alright so you don't want to be taught
what to do in an emergency situation
there's never gonna be a point where we
don't teach kids what to do in an
emergency situation we should teach kids
what to do an emergency situation does
this mean that we shouldn't try to stop
the shootings no it means we should but
we have different ways of doing that and
doesn't all involve seizing 300 million
guns can continue its
it's a national issue we cannot just
allow our legislators to say the
thoughts and prayers are with the
victims because that's not going to
bring them back and that's not going to
prevent us from okay stop there for a
second then one point on a couple of
things one I want to point out that this
is USA Today journalistic outlet right
USA Today is an objective journalistic
outlet this is a produced video for
every town for every town USA the gun
control group right I mean obviously
they even have in the the meaningful
music underneath right they had pay
piped in The Pianist underneath has
there ever been a piece of news coverage
that is not a piece of propaganda that
has that music piped in has that ever
happened almost here at a concert and
when you watch the news on CNN or Fox
and they're just quoting the president
do they pipe in a bunch of dramatic
music underneath of course not the whole
point of this video is to get at your
emotions which is why they're using the
music the way that they are using the
music right the whole point here is to
push an agenda and I'm just pointing
this out because again this agenda is
being swathe in the in the cloth of we
are just doing this because we care
about the students and the converse of
that is if you don't agree with the
agenda being pushed you don't care about
the students and I hate that so much I
can't even tell you this is why I'm
receiving hundreds of letters from
students today who are miffed about
being forced out there and being told
that they are somehow lesser if they
disagree with with the prevailing agenda
okay so let's let's do a little bit more
of this audio here because it really is
astonishing this is for the future for
76 who don't have a graduation or
thankful I was alive to can do what they
wanted to do with Christmas and we are
at the beginning of something that is
long overdue and I
begin to express how proud I am to be
involved everyone is somehow connected
to someone of gun violence and someone
who suffer from mass shooting and
there's so many that it's just rocking
the world right now okay again this is
this dramatically dramatic video the
voiceovers if you're not seeing this
we're just listening to this later then
what it's actually showing in the video
is not just the faces of the students
who are talking and crying it's actually
showing videos of all the people walking
out it's showing this dramatic video
with with the rising music the swelling
music from the end of The Truman Show
right you're supposed to feel something
when you watch this that's the goal it's
why the media is covering this the way
that it is and the sort of propaganda
being put out by the students is
obviously not well informed I'm not
gonna say that the students you know are
know exactly what they're saying I think
in many cases they're just adopting
talking points that they're being
cheered for people respond to applause
and the media are cheering folks they're
putting them on Bill Maher and they're
putting them on Ellen and they're doing
all of this in the aftermath of a
shooting because they want to push in at
Kyle cash of button they're a bunch of
students like in by the way he's not the
only one and Marjory Stoneman Douglas
high school and they're a bunch of
students who are writing me none of
these kids are being put on TV they're
not being put on TV because the media
agree with certain of these kids but do
not agree with others of these kids okay
here's another one of these students
talking about how yeah this is one of
the rallies that was the one in
Washington DC talking about how getting
shot at any moment is an American
thought through all their struggles they
never had to worry about someone barging
into their classroom with an assault
rifle and slaughtering everyone in their
class that is an American tragedy
they never had to think about getting
shot at any moment that's an American
thought and they never had to worry that
their child would be the victim of mass
shooting
that's an American worry okay first of
all that's not true all over the world
there are people who are worried about
being victims of terror attacks in the
West there are people who are worried
about being victims of violence there
they're people worried about lots of
stuff but again one of the reasons that
if you ask kids all over the world all
over the United States what are the
chances that you're going to be shot in
in a mass shooting
the the numbers I'm sure people would
wildly exaggerated right people always
think that they are that they are likely
to be shot in a crime they're likely to
be killed they're likely murdered
and the chances of that happen in the
United States are extraordinarily low
the chances of you being shot in a mass
shooting in the United States are
extraordinarily low they are the the
lifetime risk of being killed in the
United States by any firearm according
to the National Safety Council is one in
358 the lifetime risk of dying in a mass
shooting is one in 110,000 which is the
same chance of dying from a dog attack
or a legal execution in the United
States and school shooting it's even
lower than that a school shooting it's
like one in millions I believe so the
notion that all of these kids are
sitting around worried about being shot
maybe that's because of the media
coverage but it is certainly not true
that your chances are very high of being
shot in the classroom or that you should
waste a lot of time worrying about it as
a general rule it's just not true
so again it's it's really it's really
foolish the the Safe Schools Initiative
says that is according to campus safety
the odds of a high school student
getting into a fight at at school are
one in seven but that means that the
chances that you will be killed this
chance that you will be killed in a
school shooting are less than 1 in 1
million but we're being told that this
is an American thought this is something
that kids are thinking only because of
the media what you to think about these
school shootings everyday so that they
can push the idea that we ought to
remove guns from American society okay
here's another student who is saying
that he's going that the kids should
fight back and prevent the schools from
from being turned into prisons right we
shouldn't arm guards because cool school
shouldn't be prisons again the the
prison guards are there to keep you in
school
okay the armed guards at schools are not
gonna shoot students who walk out of
school they're gonna shoot people
get in to kill the students it's just
ridiculous but again this is propaganda
nonsense and I believe that as students
we need to make a few things clear to
start we will not sit in classrooms with
armed teachers we refuse to learn in
fear we reject turning our schools into
prisons and no one is turning schools
into prisons I mean when I was in when I
was in public school I felt like I was
in prison but that's not the same thing
okay then first of all all kids think
school is prison but second of all the
notion that this is so silly it's so
silly you're saying you don't want an
armed guard at school to protect you
from from a piece of crap who barges in
with a gun to a mirror to murder you
because it feels like a prison there
kids all over the world who are actually
going to school in situations where it
is basically like a prison right if
you're in Afghanistan and you're going
to school it's gonna protect it like a
prison because otherwise terrorists are
gonna barge in but this is it's just
nonsense it's just nonsense and because
it's nonsense it's being pushed by the
media the media know that if they had a
35 year old on TV saying the stuff that
these kids are saying they'd be laughed
off TV so instead they put up a bunch of
seventeen year olds to say it and
pretend that it has some sort of added
intellectual way okay before I go any
further and I want to talk about some
some storming Daniels news because the
media are fawning over storming the
annuals and in a pretty shocking way
first I want to say thank you to our
sponsors over at policy genius so life
insurance is incredibly important but
most people or at least a huge
percentage of people don't think about
it until it's too late right four and
ten people do not have it in the United
States maybe you are one of those people
maybe you haven't thought about life
insurance well if you haven't thought
about life insurance you should now
because afterward when you're dead ain't
gonna matter make sure that your family
is protected life insurance rates are
the lowest they've been in 20 years and
the best time to buy is now the best
place to buy is policy genius calm so
here's how it works you go to policy
genius calm so it's policy genius and
they've made comparing and buying life
insurance easy policy genius calm in
just five minutes you compare quotes
from over 15 life insurance providers
and when you compare the quotes that's
competitive shopping and you save money
they've helped four million people shop
for insurance they've placed over twenty
billion dollars in coverage
they don't just insure life they insure
everything in it so they insure health
insurer disability pets renters
insurance policy genius calm you get
your quotes you apply in minutes it is
that easy you should do it right now
like literally just pause where you are
go to policy genius calm
apply right now for your life insurance
make sure you are covered because you
never know the rest of this show could
be so shocking you don't make it through
the rest so make sure that your family
is protected at policy genius.com it is
the easiest way to compare and buy life
insurance don't be one of those people
caught with your pants down or your head
off make sure that you are actually a
person who has protected your family
policy genius.com it's not pleasant to
think about life insurance but once you
once you do you've made your family safe
so check that out all right so meanwhile
a lot of how about breaking out about
stormy Daniels so stormy Daniels his
lawyer is out there speaking to the
press stormy Daniels is supposed to do a
60 minutes exclusive so I guess the
storm Yanis was lawyer I guess is doing
an exclusive on 60 minutes on Sunday so
the lawyers name is Michael a vanetti
and Trump of course has essentially sued
stormy Daniels trying to get stormy
Daniels not to talk about the fact that
they were that they were knocking boots
back in 2007 the year 2006 the year
after Baron Trump was born and while
Trump was already married of Melania now
number one no one in the United States
cares about this because Trump is
garbage with women okay just putting it
out there not not with all women okay
Trump is nice to many women I'm sure but
his sex life garbage this has been true
since the 70s this is a guy who said
over and over and over that he was
avoiding STDs in the 1970s was like the
Vietnam War for him he really said that
and there's a guy who said things like
what nothing in life matters unless you
have a young and beautiful piece of ass
right so this is not somebody who is
somebody you want babysitting your 17
year old daughter right became a
president Trump has a long and a Farias
connection with various women of the
tawdry women women of the evening and
you know he's been married three times
he's cheated on all three of his wives
he cheated on wife number one with
flight number two cheated on the wife
number two with wife number three and
she done wife number three with stormy
Daniels among others so this is not a
guy who any of this stuff is going to
cling to and nobody cares because we all
know who he is
there's no new information added to the
system but the new information the media
are trying to add to the system is that
Trump paid off stormy Daniels to shut up
right before the election now Trump has
said I didn't know anything about it it
was just my lawyer my lawyer gave one
hundred and thirty thousand dollars to
stormy Daniels out of the goodness of
his heart which is one hell of a lawyer
like let me find that lawyer the lawyer
who just gives away money it sounds like
an awesome lawyer to make obviously
Trump knew about it let's not
and anyone who says differently is
saying silly talk anyway so I haven't
had a vanetti debunked the notion that
trumps attorney Michael Kohn negotiated
with stormy Daniels on a nondisclosure
agreement independently of the Trump
Organization he says I do not understand
why Michael Cohen if he was acting in
his own capacity why he'd reach out to
the general counsel of the Trump
Organization to get involved in the
arbitration that's what she Anderson
Cooper said in agreement with having
that here's what it looked like last
night on CNN the focus of this filing in
February was to gag my client put a
muzzle on her and prevent her from from
speaking and that's why they filed the
arbitration to obtain what's called a
temporary restraining order so this idea
that there is a separation between EC
LLC and Donald Trump and the Trump
Organization is a complete and utter
fiction okay so this is probably true I
mean the again I don't think that
Trump's lawyer was walking around
signing hundred and thirty thousand
dollar checks just for the hell of it
but does this make a big difference well
not necessarily because number one it
may not be a campaign finance violation
john john edwards directly paid nine
hundred thousand dollars to his mistress
who's then pregnant with his child
during the 2004 presidential election
cycle and nothing happened right it was
totally fine actually during 2008
presidential election cycle and nothing
happened it was totally fine whose never
prosecute or anything like that so it's
not necessarily illegal a lot of people
I'm left suggesting that this would
somehow change the math on Trump why
would this change the math on Trump
I'm just wondering I I don't see
anything here that changes what we knew
about Trump I don't know anybody in the
United States who thinks that Trump is
the is the great bringer of male
morality to leads of the world so if
this is the great hope for bringing down
Trump I think that this is silly now I
will point something else out there has
been a lot of questions about Monica
Lewinsky versus stormy Daniels why is
the media went after Monica Lewinsky why
is the media ripped apart Linda Tripp
why is it the media went after Kathleen
Willey and Paula Jones well they did
nothing of the sort with stormy Daniels
stormy Daniels who is not alleging
sexual harassment or assault by the
President of the United States right
Kathleen Willey alleged sexual assault
by the President of the United States
Paula Jones alleged sexual harassment
and assault by the president before he
was the president Juanita Broderick
alleged rape none of these women were
treated with respect they're all tree
like garbage by the media for
legitimately decades stormy Daniels
who's a porn star who had consensual sex
with the president before he was the
president and then was paid off by the
president in a contract that she signed
and she took the money and now she wants
to talk about it now she's being treated
as some sort of victim she's being
treated as some sort of heroine for
coming out and speaking oh the bravery
of stormy Daniels hey now I don't have
to like Trump sexual behavior in order
to recognize that stormy Daniels is not
exactly the Virgin Mary I don't have to
recognize that I don't have to believe
that Trump is great with women to
recognize that stormy Daniels is not
exactly standing up out of the vapir
sense of righteous indignation and
virtue that's not what's happening here
but the media are treating her that way
why are the media treating her that way
so it's really funny if you look at
lefty commentaries what they're saying
is well they're treating her this way
because it's different we're now living
in the me2 moment don't you see it's
that that's changed right if this had
happened with the Democratic president
and a porn star we'd be treating this
differently um mm-hmm
wrong okay all that's changed is that
there's a Republican in office and the
Republican in office should be slapped
around as much as possible if this were
a Democrat in office and if this were
Barack Obama and he had sex with a porn
star and paid her off to keep silent
people would have said this is a sexual
matter everybody lies about sex we get
exactly the same we'd say was consensual
because this was consensual we did
exactly the same crap that we got when
Bill Clinton was president because the
media are filled with Democrats okay if
you didn't believe it from all the
talking about gun control the media are
filled top-to-bottom with Democrats and
so they're treating stormy Daniels as
though she's anything but a porn star
who wants to make a little extra money
by telling lewd stories out of school
about the president's junk which is
really what this is okay meanwhile in
other news the president is is bringing
onboard larry cudlow larry cudlow is a
free trader i mentioned this yesterday
he's going to head up the National
Economic Council what's really funny
about this of course is that Gary Cohn
and Larry Kudlow have very similar
economic policies Kudlow is a free
trader he's a lazy a fair economist Gary
Cohn is a free trader he may be more
interventionist in some ways than Larry
Kudlow is actually and so Kudlow is
being brought on board to fill a slot
that probably never should have been
emptied in the first place here is Como
describing how Trump buttered him up
I've been around a while my head has not
turned easily I served in the White
House etcetera etcetera
but just to talk to him for 30 40
minutes with a clip three four days in a
row was a wonderful thing I just want to
say that it's a wonderful thing and he
and I have known each other many years
I've interviewed him on radio and TV I
was in the campaign helping out I know
him you know reasonably well and it was
just a terrific experience I don't want
to sound sophomoric but it was just a
really good thing so I will say I think
that it is very funny that the president
basically hired Kudlow because he thinks
that Kudlow is on TV a lot right and
he's about to do the same thing that
Pete had said Seth over at Fox News the
rumor is that the current Secretary of
the VA who stinks right Eric Shulkin
he's awful that he's about to be ousted
which he should be in favor of Pete
hagseth who Trump likes because he's on
TV in fact there was a report last week
that Trump during a meeting with his VA
secretary actually called up headset on
the phone they said he'd just seen him
on Fox & Friends and wanted to get him
in on the conversation so the president
is governing by TV which listen if he's
got the right people from TV I'm happy
about that that's fine I mean Obama said
that he governed by TV because he never
saw anything bad that happened in his
administration until I saw it on the
roof I saw it on TV right so at least if
we're gonna govern by TV hopefully Trump
will pick some of the best commentators
from TV and bring those people into his
administration but it is funny that he's
replacing a free trader with a free
trader okay so meanwhile Trump had
there's a story in The Washington Post
about how Trump talks about trade with
foreign leaders it's pretty astonishing
it's pretty amazing we'll talk about
that in just a second first you're going
to have to go over to daily wire.com and
subscribe for $9.99 a month you get a
subscription to daily wire that means
you get the rest of the show live
Russell Clavin show Live Writer
Knowles's show live plus you get to be
part of our mailbag we're doing it to
tomorrow so if you have big questions
life-altering questions you want to ask
to me and you want them answered live on
the air then all you have to do is go
over to Daley wire.com and subscribe
then you watch the show live and you
type questions into our chat box and we
pick them up as you are asking them and
I will answer them for you on air plus
if you send us emails through our throw
mechanism then I will answer questions
that way as well so check that out with
the subscription also you get the annual
subscription $99 a year you get this the
leftist here is hot or cold tumblr the
greatest of all beverage vessels you
just want to listen later make sure to
go to iTunes or SoundCloud or YouTube
please subscribe please leave us a
review it always helps us we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
all righty so president Trump apparently
it's gonna be good to have him talk to
Larry Kudlow because when the president
is talking not to Larry Kudlow he says
silly things this is an amazing story
from the Washington Post president
Trumbo stood in a fundraising speech on
Wednesday that he made up information in
a meeting with the leader of a top US
ally saying he insisted to Canadian
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau that the
United States runs a trade deficit with
its neighbor to the north without
knowing whether this was true and here's
what Trump said he said Trudeau came to
see me he's a good guy Justin he said no
no we have no trade deficit with you we
have none Donald please nice guy
good-looking guy comes in Donna
we have no trade deficit he's very proud
because everybody else you know we're
getting killed so he's proud I said
wrong Justin wrong you do I didn't even
know I had no idea I just said you're
wrong you know why because we're just
stupid and I thought they were smart I
said you're wrong Justin he said nope
we have no trade deficit I said well in
that case I feel differently but I don't
believe it
I said one of our four guys out his guy
my guy they went on I said check because
I can't believe it well sir you're
actually right we have no deficit but
that doesn't include energy and timber
when he do we lose 17 billion a year
okay so Trump basically just made it
operate he goes into a meeting with
Trudeau and he wants to rip on him over
the trade deficit because Trump is under
the wildness impression the trade
deficits inevitably mean American
economic decline that silly means
sometimes trade deficits are bad
sometimes trade deficits are good what
is more important is your trade policy a
free trade policy makes your country
richer a non free trade policy makes our
country poorer and there's a whole
article in the Journal of American
greatness which I'm writing a response
to as soon as this show is over about
how I get free trade wrong like me
personally to which I would say then you
need to talk to every economist for the
past 200 years because the notion that
you're going to make an economy better
with tariffs by protecting certain
industries is just silly and there's a
more complex argument that is made over
a journal of American greatness so
you'll have to go over later at Daley
where maybe I'll talk about it tomorrow
a little bit on the show but again Trump
is under this impression that if we just
tear off everybody to death then this
makes America stronger he believes in a
policy of autarky okay autarky is
something that the Germans under the
riot that used to the Third Reich that
used to want this will the idea that
your country was going to be able to
supply you all of your internal needs
they wouldn't need to trade anymore
you'd be able to produce everything
in-house was like Wakanda now obviously
this isn't
thing to do with the Nazis racial
policies I'm just talking about economic
policies the policy of autarky was
really stupid and ended up destroying
Germany and their manufacturing capacity
actually up until World War two it
really was not good for them their
economy was was not booming it booms for
the first couple years of Hitler because
it'd been so weak before that and then
it fell apart pretty quickly autarky is
never a good policy tariffs are not a
good policy and places that have high
tariffs generally have weaker economies
did that that's the statistic the
matter's trade deficits don't matter
right trade deficits I'm not saying
they're good I'm not saying they're bad
trade deficits are irrelevant
what matters is trade policy what
matters is whether your economy is
growing or not and the correlation
between the two between trade deficits
and economic growth is not clear in the
slightest it's it's it's there's a lot
of noise and not a whole lot of sound
that comes out of that okay so here's
the reality do we have a trade deficit
with Canada no we have a trade surplus
of Canada according to the Office of the
United States Trade Representative it
reports that in 2016 the United States
exported 12.5 billion dollars more in
goods and services than imported from
Canada leading to a trade surplus and
not a deficit so then Trump tweeted out
that we do have a trade deficit he said
we do have a trade deficit with Canada
as we do with almost all countries p.m.
Justin Trudeau Canada a very good guy
doesn't like saying Canada has a surplus
V us but they do they almost all do and
that's how I know that's not evidence
dude that's you just saying the same
thing that you just said so that's kind
of weird and then it got weirder Trump
made a blistering attack against major
US allies in global economies according
to the Washington Post accusing the EU
China Japan and South Korea of ripping
off the US for decades and pillaging the
US workforce which is weird since he
keeps saying that our economic growth is
stunning and that everything is going
great so which is it is it greater as
it's sucky he also described the NAFTA
agreement as a disaster and he'd blame
on the WTO for allowing other countries
to box in the US on trade again if NAFTA
such a disaster why did he just exempt
Canada and Mexico from our steel tariffs
right he's the one who likes the steel
tariffs Trump did seem to threaten to
pull troops stationed in South Korea if
he didn't get what he wanted on trade
with Seoul this is actually a serious
problem if rum was gonna meet with kim
jeong-hoon and he's simultaneously
threatening south korea that he's gonna
pull out troops then what happens if kim
jeong-hoon says listen i'll get rid of
my nuclear program and you just get rid
of the troops in south korea
the answer is disaster because if trump
actually wants to move the troops out of
south korea suddenly south korea falls
into the orbit of the chinese
opposed to being an American satellite
state to a certain extent but Trump said
our allies care about themselves they
don't care about us this perspective is
so wrong and it's so bad and it's such a
mistake we care about our allies because
we think that it's in our interest to do
so
not out of the goodness of our heart but
I'm really hoping Larry Kudlow can can
drill some sense into the president
because this is not smart so again this
was just on Wednesday that he was saying
all of this the best part of the speech
is when he started talking specifically
about Japan he said Japan uses gimmicks
to deny US auto companies access to its
consumers so here's what he said he said
it's called the bowling ball test do you
know what that is that's where they take
a bowling ball from 20 feet up in the
air and they drop it on the hood of a
car and if the hood dent the car doesn't
qualify well guess what the roof tends
in a little bit and they said nope this
car doesn't qualify it's horrible the
way were treated it's horrible um no one
knows what he's talking about there is
no test where they take a bowling ball
and drop it on top of a car in Japan to
determine what the car should be
imported to Japan that doesn't exist
that's like what hmm there's not a car
manufactured in existence that would not
dent if you dropped a bowling ball on
the hood from 20 feet up in the air
Trump said he didn't even want Japan to
pay tariffs but to build more
automobiles in the u.s. saying that he
just wants Japan well if you want Japan
to actually move more automobile
manufacturing to the United States they
already build tons of autos in the
United States Japan does so does South
Korea well if you want them to do that
so did German companies by the way all
you have to do is lower the tax burden
in the United States which is one of the
things that Trump has done by lowering
the corporate tax rates he said the free
trade globalists are against his trade
moves because they're worldly people
they have stuff on the other side here
he's accusing anyone who believes in
free trade of wanting to impoverish the
United States again this is so dumb if
you actually believe that the United
States is stronger by taxing its
citizens and inordinately high rates
you're out of your mind they this is
what people forget about tariffs a
tariff is just a tax it is a tax on
everyone to the benefit of a few so the
only argument that's been made on behalf
of tariffs is basically these industries
are so important they are so vital that
everybody in the United States should be
taxed in order to benefit that few
people remember that's what a tariff
does it's not punishing foreign
companies nearly as much as as punishing
American consumers so even if China is
quote-unquote cheating right like
they're subsidizing their own program
well so are we salutes the idea is that
they're taxing their citizens in order
to subsidize a particular industry and
generate a product for cheap is that an
argument that we should tax our own
citizens to do the same why is raising
taxes on our citizens making anything
better the question is better for whom
better for the federal government
because now they get to pick and choose
which industries they like or better for
the consumer the answer certainly is not
better for the consumer it's not even
better for job creation inside the
United States
so again Larry Larry Kudlow Godspeed my
friend I please talk some sense into the
president over all of us ok now
meanwhile there's still hubbub occurring
over Katy Perry so I discussed this
briefly yesterday now we actually have
the clip so apparently on a new American
Idol which is on ABC Katy Perry who I
don't know when she morphed into this
bizarre-looking
like Hunger Games refugee um you know
she was used to be a pretty girl I mean
with all but with the long hair this
haircut is not flattering to Katy Perry
and I don't know who did her makeup it
looks as though she walked into a door
covered with makeup basically but you
know enough ripping on Katy Perry's
appearance she's a naturally beautiful
person obviously but Katy Perry was on
American Idol she's the one of the
judges and one is 19 year old guy on
American Idol comes in to audition and
here's what happens what on the cheek he
didn't even make this much
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so it turns out this guy actually
was not particularly happy about the
situation he said that he was trying to
save his first kiss with somebody he
actually gave a crap about which seems
like a nice thing to me right I had the
same policy myself you know I think that
this is and he was humiliated for this
of course everybody's laughing about
this now imagine the double standard
here for just a second imagine for a
second that it was not in fact this guy
and Katy Perry it was one of her male
co-hosts in a 19 year old girl and the
19 year-old girl said I've never been
kissed and the co-host said come on over
here come on over here I won't give me a
kiss on the cheek okay first of all even
that would be considered sexual
harassment but just that much would be
considered sexual harassment then
imagine that she came over said okay
fine I'll give you kiss on the cheek and
he immediately swiveled and gave her a
peck on the lips that guy would be fired
his career would be over he would be
done right the reason there's two
reasons why people are not taking this
seriously one good and one bad okay the
reason the batteries and why people are
not taking this seriously is because
there is this view in American culture
that sex is an ultimate good not that
it's good within certain confines but
it's sex and sexual activity and the
kissing and all this stuff that it's
good under any circumstances right the
Pleasantville view of sex have you ever
seen the movie Pleasantville which is an
awful film the first 30 minutes of the
film is really good and then the and
then the rest of the movies garbage so
the basic concept of the film is that
there's a bunch of people who are living
in modern times and Tobey Maguire loves
watching this show called Pleasantville
from the 1950s where everything is
really clean cut and really that
everybody's very nice to each other and
then he somehow get sucked back into
that with his sister and his sister is
basically in the movie promiscuous and
sexually active and she goes back there
and she brings color to the lives of all
the people of Pleasantville with her
sexual liberation because obviously
modern morality is better than 1950s
morality
despite the rates of says CDs and single
motherhood everything is better now than
it was then so the way that you liberate
people is through sex not through
commitment not through obligation the
way that you make people free is through
random sexual activity so this guy
should just be happy because after all
Katy Perry just kissed stunning Katy
Perry's famous and Katy Perry is
beautiful so therefore he should be a
happy camper his consent doesn't matter
at all because any sort of sexual
activity is fine but that obviously is
not the whole story
there's also the part of the story that
he's a male and she's a female so when a
woman is sexually forward this is
considered also an ultimate good
a man is sexually forward this is
considered usually an ultimate bad right
if a man has done this to a girl then I
think everybody would rightly say that's
bad the reason they would say that's bad
is because the male aggressive sexual
instinct is considered rapey but the
female aggressive sexual instinct which
does happen in some females certainly
not as common as among males that is
considered women's empowerment so Katy
Perry's empowered says she can do
whatever she wants even if the guy
doesn't want it okay so that is the the
bad reason why people are ignoring this
the good reason why people are ignoring
this to a certain extent is because
there is and it's not really a good
reason it's a mediocre reason is because
of course there's a double standard of
course there's a double standard no one
sees the male sexual instinct in the way
that they see the female sexual instinct
no one sees Katy Perry is a sexual
predator because she's a woman
no one would see a man doing this as
anything about a sexual predator because
he's a man there's a good reason for
that because there are natural
differences between men and women it may
be a dramatic over rate of the situation
right - to extend it - Kate what Katy
Perry did here and say that's okay but
it is true that human beings see a
natural difference between men and women
which is why we treat these situations
differently and yet we as a society deny
that those differences exist which is
this really bizarre thing that we do and
really stupid also one things that bugs
me about this particularly is this guy
was basically shamed right why would he
be offended you know because virginity
until marriage is stupid and kissing
until love waiting to kiss until love
that's stupid - yeah as it is a
proactive but is a real advocate for
that position that you should wait until
marriage that you should reserve
physical intimacy for the person that
you love and are committed to for life I
think that you know this is just another
you just throw another branch on the
fire in the in the conflagration that
each Western values from the from the
inside okay that's a pretty deep read on
a pretty minor incident but let's get to
some things that I like and then some
things that I hate so today things that
I like so we've been doing we've been
doing books about socialism so of course
the classic on this topic is is
Solzhenitsyn's Gulag Archipelago
archipelago this is about the prison
system in the in the Soviet Union from
1918 to 1956 this book was largely
responsible for the collapse of the
Soviet Union or at least the moral
legitimacy of the Soviet Union in the
West remember that for a lot of Western
leftists the Soviet Union was a place
that was good it was a place that that
was to be worth
lating right it provided a new vision of
the future Lincoln Steffens the
journalist went over to the Soviet Union
and said I've seen the future and it
works from Walter Durant's he went over
there during the Ukrainian famine in
1932 and he said everything's fine there
all this talk about starvation it's
nonsense and people thought the Soviet
Union was the wave of the future until
this book came out this book was banned
in the Soviet Union and it was smuggled
to the west it is a masterwork I mean
it's it's very long it is but it is
worth the read Solzhenitsyn was a
communist he started off as a communist
then he ended up in the in the gulag and
he talks about what the dehumanization
of socialism and communism do to people
well worth the read obviously one of the
great books in the world really in the
history of the world the Gulag
Archipelago ocupado is a series of
islands by Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn okay
time for some things that I hate so
Senator Rand Paul obviously civil
libertarian and he's been very much
opposed to for example the Bush
administration policy of treating
prisoners of war as terrorists captured
abroad not as prisoners of war but as
but as detainees as unlawful combatants
and the use of enhanced interrogation
techniques on them now it is true that
enhanced interrogation techniques
allowed us to get information from
Khalid Sheikh Mohammed one of the
organizers of 9/11 we wouldn't have
otherwise been able to get but Rand Paul
has been adamantly and steadfastly
opposed to that that's fine
what's not fine is him slandering Gina
Hass ball so Gina Hass ball is Trump's
pick to lead the CIA and she oversaw a
secret prison in Thailand which was used
for rendition and she's been bashed for
that because the idea here is that we
should never have used rendition in
addition program is that terrorists
would be captured abroad instead
bringing them back home we would hand
them over to US ally and those people
would be able to use methods that we
would not approve here in the United
States according to the New York Times
she ran a president codenamed cat's eye
and that began her deep involvement in
the agency's counterterrorism operation
showed her willingness to take part in
the agency's rendition detention and
interrogation program which shaped her
career this is when she was younger and
she was rising in the organization she's
the first woman who had become the head
of the CIA if she were appointed there's
no evidence that she enjoys torture
Maran Paul decides that this is where
he's gonna go well there was a book
and about the torture treatment the
waterboarding and Sofer comments were
basically gleeful well the man can't
breathe and he's choking on saliva and
water and she's saying oh you're a good
actor and it's it's you know can't
believe a grown man's crying because of
this treatment and it almost seemed to
be a little bit of Glee and her voice
the check to enjoy the torture and I
think that's not who we need to lead the
CIA there are many career officials at
the CIA who would be perfectly competent
to do this but we should not reward
somebody who actually participated in
torture trick ok there's but there's a
particular problem with this is that
he's completely misquoting the book ok
the book does not even mention Haspel so
here's the US intelligence official
quote Senator Paul's claims today about
Geena Haspel are not only inaccurate but
contradicted by the very source
materials he relied on the senator
quotes liberally from page 263 of James
Mitchell's book enhanced interrogation
in describing the interrogation of Abu
Zubaydah by the way I was divided one of
the worst terrorists in modern history
in claiming that miss Haskell was the
CIA chief of base who was present and
expressing joy at this interrogation a
reading of the same page demonstrates
the chief of base President and quoted
during this event was a man not Gina
Hass ball this is one of many false
claims about miss Haskell being peddled
by the uninformed right and the author
was on fox business saying this is just
not true he said he's referring to a
section for my book where the chief of
bass was confronting because he was
faking confusion that chief of base was
not Gina that's the way they're going to
attack her and take things out of
context and distort them I don't think
he's deliberately distorting them I do
think someone told him something that's
not true I did not refer to her that
does not refer to her so clearly Rand
Paul Ince Gina Haspel and apology on
that score even if you don't like Gina
hospitals background Ron Wyden who is a
complete nut job from I think he's from
Washington he's Morgan I think the
Democrat from Oregon he says that
Republicans hit hospitals background
when they decided denominator the Trump
administration is engaged in an
out-and-out cover-up to keep the
American people from knowing about her
professional background as you know
there have been many public stories
linking her to torture I'm a John McCain
guy on these issues John McCain says
it's not right morally and he points out
it's not effective and the
matías the CIA has actually lied to the
American people and to the Congress they
have claimed the torture stop terrorist
plots there's no evidence of that
so I and senator Martin Heinrich have
led the effort to get this nominees
background Declassified I can tell you
they're hey nobody's trying to hide
anything people know that Jena Haspel
was involved in the waterboard program
and in the rendition program the
question is was it legal at the time
number one number two was it immoral I
think it's still questionable as to
whether it was immoral I think that that
waterboarding terrorists for information
that could prevent a future terrorist
attacks I am NOT going to pretend that I
think that that's a terrible thing I
don't think that's a terrible thing at
all okay so we will be here tomorrow
we'll be back to discuss all the news
plus the mailbag so if you're going to
subscribe today's a good day to do it
because that makes sure that you can get
your questions in you can email us and
you can also come and watch the show
live and ask me questions I'll get your
answers live on air so check that out
please $9.99 a month again $99 a year
and that always helps us that makes sure
that we can pay our bills we appreciate
it
you're listening to the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua Oliveira the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright for
publishing 2018